[Music]
howdy-ho reject nation it's Sunday God's
day and because it's God's day a person
whose channel we haven't seen a video
from in forever
who loves having reactions done to his
videos got a video out for something
that I really want to see Oh No Avengers
infinity war weird trailer
ah the John's my Italian brother in
hitch from the - a force a Leal
[Music]
[Music]
to balance
[Music]
[Music]
Hammond's newspaper
[Music]
[Music]
do I know that movie good job
ah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
Seavers
so much Toby
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
aha that that's brilliant
yeah that's brilliant
[Music]
[Music]
Wow
to Redmond
[Music]
we will gladly leave a like Aldo I will
leave a like let's leave a like explicit
good sponsor just six hours man thank
you you know I can never find your [ __ ]
out though
so I'm not going to try
[Music]
that is a crazy dude Wow hey man that's
what the internet is for is proving that
somebody out there can do it is it you
probably not know
[Music]
translations international weird
trailers good for you Aldo thanks buddy
thanks buddy for pollutants to get you
know I might not say that's the best one
he's done but it's definitely their
craziest one he's done it's arguably the
weirdest arguably the weirdest one he's
done there's a lot of Tobey Maguire in
that one man yes Tobey Maguire is that
his animations like TG stuff's getting
better the marge Ruffalo one though
vision arguably for infinity war this is
the one where you have to go the
craziest on it dude Thor at the stack of
laundry machines got me pretty good and
the whole Rick and Morty show yeah you
got just get schwifty things oh that was
brilliant though with Thanos with the
pins of 20th Century Fox Marvel Star
Wars on the Mickey Mouse ed that's
that's pretty good that's a brilliant
joke yeah because a lot of it you know
Aldo just goes weird and crazy he's
probably stoned or something and
creating the weirdest jokes I think of
but that one is like a brilliant joke
real-life colors yeah that was hilarious
man
I love this shot at all that running at
the end - you got Logan there flash
black panther Ed Helms of Superman but
that's actually Ben Affleck that helps
me at first you got is Shrek in there
you got a man the background and Tomb
Raider of Wonder Woman oh dude this is
this is fantastic man I love the opening
you know when they did the Marvel logo
and different movies and he did his own
with all of this classic weird trailers
yeah he did all those classic literature
- the bet Ben Affleck dancing it's a
great ending with Jay and Silent Bob at
the perfect choice man and a cursory
choice dude congratulations this is
amazing seriously great job al enjoy
very much appreciate hope to hear from
you soon page from the day shout-out for
Sally L Sally is a girl who's become
pretty big pledge of ours on patreon and
there's so many reward tiers that with
her pledge that we have to honor and
she's not asking for like anything man
get a video request whatever you want us
to do you also get a Google hangout with
us and right now you're feeling pretty
shy to do a Google hangout with us I
understand you're from Canada Canadians
tend to be pretty shy folks so I'm sorry
that you're nervous do Google hang all
this movie would love to get to know you
we would love to see your beautiful face
we'd love to hear your voice and if you
have to you know wider idea genre and I
will just talk on the camera and you
could hide your face and just type to us
if that's what it takes so long
conversation with us yeah you could just
talk audio and not even turn on you I've
tried she's super nervous although
you're really good with your grammar man
like when you type us messages you are
so well good with your own Larry so well
good I just really want to see what you
look like because someone who's as smart
as you who was damn old it here I got it
I got the whole list here you dabble to
being a writer journalist lawyer
copywriter
you just seem so smart with all the
knowledge you have nothing is hotter
than being smart so already in my book
you are one fine piece of ass Sally
yeah and nothing's better than being
well good don't make fun of me only I
make fun of you sorry yeah that's how
the world are sensitive I just want to
be like our leader yeah yeah a hundred
percent making a making the real rejects
great again
but seriously Sally you are a very
bright girl you have a pretty big
imagination so I would love to get to
know you over a Google hangout so I hope
you reconsider your choice and actually
talk and show us your face because I
want to see you and hear you my dear
oh that's mine this is my favorite when
you do this blow make out alright guys
well Aldo thank you subscribe to Aldo
immediately what are you doing with your
life subscribe to a low tones you can
subscribe to us click that notification
bell whenever you like catch you on the
flippety-flip home skillets